this one is very interesting have you
ever heard of this guy before don't
don't google i want to tell you the
story so don't don't google this guy all
right let me tell you the story i'm just
i i google them i'm just thinking oh wow
okay yeah uh young guy young guy 29
years old i don't know
name is wow sam bankman freed i think
it's the way you say his name
and uh when you if you heard him talk
like i actually want you to listen to a
youtube video for a second because he
sounds like you know an absolute dweeb
and i loved it i was like oh this guy
sounds like he would be a self-made
billionaire by the age of 29 because he
sounds like a genius he sounds like a
tech genius have you brought this person
up to me before no i just discovered him
like two days ago okay so what's this
guy's story
so
this guy you know i'll just come sam for
short but uh so this guy's sam he's a he
he's a young guy he's very smart um
he takes a job as kind of like a hedge
fund trader or something like that with
a group called jane street i guess and
uh i don't know forget these details
they don't really matter guys got a job
in finance
and um he leaves and he starts something
called alameda research and it's called
alameda research because he needed it to
sound as legit as possible and not like
what it actually was so what was it so
what this guy did was he was into crypto
and there was this known thing in crypto
where
as crypto was getting popular this is
around 2017 when the first big run-up
happened and bitcoin went you know from
three thousand dollars to twenty
thousand dollars and it crashed later
but during that time 2016 2017-2018
bitcoin was emerging and there was this
as any new thing there's these like kind
of
uh
it's like the wild wild west a little
bit and so there was this thing where in
the u.s
the price of bitcoin was let's say ten
thousand dollars of bitcoin
and in other countries where
um the exchanges weren't built or the
com the country had some regulations or
whatever there was like a premium for
bitcoin there was more demand than there
was bitcoin available to buy in those
countries uh because you need like let's
say like in korea there was a famous
uh thing called the kimchi the kimchi
premium and the kimchi premium was that
in korea there wasn't uh kimchi like the
uh
like the the food so this was known as
the kimchi premium and basically it was
like uh whatever bitcoin was selling for
here let's say it was ten thousand
dollars in korea it was trading for
fifteen thousand dollars because it was
that big it was about 50 premium and it
fluctuated obviously and i think 30 was
kind of like the average of the kimchi
premium over time so everybody wanted
this so everybody you know any smart
person saw oh wow there's an arbitrage
what if i could just buy it in the u.s
for 10 grand and immediately sell it in
korea for 15 grand or for 30 you know 13
grand and so you had this like ability
to flip it and so a whole bunch of
people were trying to do this but there
was all these problems right like
well the reason you know the reason
wasn't the reason there was this premium
is because it was hard
to buy bitcoin in korea so one idea was
you buy it in the us off the us exchange
you go to korea and you sell it but
you're gonna sell it for in the korean
you know wan which is like the local
currency
but now you need to like for the for the
arbitrage to continue you have to
convert the korean wan back to dollars
to go buy more
go buy more bitcoin in the u.s the
problem was you can't convert the korean
wand back to dollars easily because the
government was very like tight fisted
regulations you couldn't funnel large
amounts of money from the korean wand
back to dollars very very easily so a
whole bunch of people were trying to get
this like pinata of money and they
couldn't crack it
and what this guy did was he was like
okay the kimchi premium he went for
the japan premium which was far less
appealing it was only 10
but he's like still
if i can if i could trade a us bitcoin
for 10 more in japan every day i'm
making 10 compounding daily
and so he went through this like odyssey
where for like a year
all he's doing is setting up this trade
so he like
for actually by the way first when he
was trying to figure out could i capture
the kimchi premium he was like doing
calculations like
if i filled up if i charted a private
plane and i filled it up with a hundred
people and i flew you know they buy
bitcoin in the us i flew them all to
korea and then they you know sell it
there and then i could each one of them
could convert some amount of that money
and i could fly them back and every day
i could fly this plane back and forth
between us and korea like could i make
it work and he was like i don't think it
works so wait so you had to be there
physically it's not that you had to be
there physically you have to do all like
all legs of the transaction so you have
to be able to buy in korea or like sell
your bitcoin in korea at the premium but
now you have korean won now you need to
convert that to dollars and so how do
you do that you need to convert it there
but there's caps they won't let you
convert it because the way he described
it is like look
he's like what i wanted to do
essentially was to be
you know selling five million dollars of
bitcoin for the local currency and
converting five million of local
currency back to us dollars every day
it's like if you if you just go to like
go to korea go to japan go to wherever
and you say hey i'd like to
it's like a one-way flow of money i have
five million dollars of your local
currency i'd like to convert it to
dollars and exit the country um and
they're like okay but where are you
getting all this money and why are you
doing such a large amount like what is
this yeah he's like you know
if you if you go to bank school 101
that's like money laundering that's what
money laundering looks like that that is
what money laundering that is exactly
what money laundering looks like so he's
like even though i'm not money
laundering i'm buying and selling a good
that's differently priced in different
regions to them on the ground to the
bank on the ground where i need to do
these conversions it's shady it's too
shady they won't let me do it so he
spends like a year of his life where
he's like goes to japan
now he's got to find uh
he's got to do each each one of these
was hard so anyways then the net end of
this story is this guy's arbitraging 25
million dollars a day
of of this currency he's making a 10
compounding uh you know margin
every single day and this guy you know
in the three years basically he's become
a self-made billionaire he's worth 10
billion dollars now which is a
combination of
the money he made from the arbitrage
trade as well as he then created his own
exchange um and like you know so he has
a trading company that's you know has
made hundreds of millions of dollars on
this arbitrage and then he built he used
that to create an exchange which is
worth billions of dollars on paper so
anyways this guy's worth 10 billion
dollars he
and his
because uh the currency is called ftx
right that's his exchange his exchange
called fps sorry sorry exchange and
uh that is is that basically an
alternative to basically a more higher
end it's a more sophisticated coinbase
where you can do like derivatives trades
option trades on all different types of
courses internationally and that's like
and that's like a proper company it's a
proper company with like so follow me on
research made hundreds of millions of
dollars in the span of a few months just
doing this one trade over and over again
every day so i'm going to describe a
couple things but he got on people's
radar because he was the biggest donor
to joe biden this year in the campaign
he wrote a he wrote like a five million
dollar check at the last hour like at
the 11th hour that let joe do like you
know as part of this like you know last
minute blitz they did on tv ads in all
the swing states uh because this is kind
of interesting this guy's like very uh
his whole business philosophy is this
thing called effective altruism which is
basically like
go be a greedy capitalist go try to make
as much money as you can and your goal
is to give at least half of it away
while you're doing it so he's got like
it's not like a philanthropist giving
away one percent of his money or 10 of
his money as a tie his goal is giving
away like 50 of his liquid liquid like
net worth you know like that he makes
every year that's his like kind of like
his mindset where did he get the money
to start this so he started it with a
very small amount of money and it just
compounded very quickly because he's
basically like getting 10 extra every
day so i i don't know exactly where he
got the initial seed capital or how big
it was he hasn't specified that but he
did say at the max they were doing 25
million a day on the trade which is
basically like a 2.5 million like you
know like profit per day uh that they
were making on the trade and so he
describes
that okay so
what he's like basically if you want to
do this you have to like break it down
into small chunks he's like okay so i
need on one side i need to be able to go
buy a ton of bitcoin in the u.s so
how do i get uh exchange in the u.s
that's going to give me really high
limits even though i'm this dorky kid
who's got no track record and i have no
like collateral or brand name and so
he's like finds a way to solve that
problem of like being able to buy 25
million dollars of bitcoin in the u.s
then he had to like go to japan and he
had to be able to sell a huge amount of
bitcoin there then he had to be able to
convert it from the japanese yen or
whatever to us dollars and he had to do
that all in the same day and wire
transfer it all back to the us to buy it
again the next day to buy the full max
amount again the next day so he's just
just like the money every day and so he
described like they would just the way
that the timing worked it was always in
the last hour of the banking day that he
would be trying to get all the wire
transfers done to get the money back to
the u.s so that they could execute
tomorrow's trade and any day that they
could what does this sound like you said
he sounds crazy like i'm looking at
pictures oh my god he sounds extremely
genuine humble high-pitched voice kind
of like just a nerdy guy
um who was like he accounted for about
10 of all the bitcoin trading himself
his alameda research during that time
period i believe which is just like
insane because he was moving so much
money dude i love these people i love i
love freaks
[Music]
you